If we want to play a video game or design a new tennis shoe, or try out
different color paints on a building, we would ideally like the experience to be
interactive. When we take an action we would like to see response from the
computer quickly enough that we don't feel slowed down. How fast is fast enough?
I'll give you a real number. It's about six frames per second. Let me show you.
So in this demo we're showing six frames per second for this frame right here.
And I can adjust that and make it look slower. So, now it's just going to update
at one frame per second and you can see that that's, that's pretty unusable.
It's sort of like you're trying to walk through molasses or something. And
you'll see up in the upper left hand corner how long each frame is taking. So if
I adjust it to say, somewhere around 19 or so. Now it's pretty good, you can
still see some jerkiness. But if I go to sixty, it becomes nice and smooth. So
now try it for yourself.